Christians just think if it looks weird,
it's wrong. If it looks weird, it's of
the devil. And I can't tell you why, but
that's just evil. And so that's why I
have a passion for talking about why
this stuff is evil. Why this how this
stuff is just infiltrating our culture
to where it's accepted and and why we
should stay away from these things. It
God isn't trying to keep anything good
away from us. There's a reason he
doesn't want you playing around
witchcraft because you're literally
messing with the demonic realm. There
was once a time when witchcraft was
considered taboo, but now is it becoming
more acceptable? Find out on this
episode of LED Live.
[Music]
Light exposing darkness.
What's up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at LED Live. We want to thank
you guys for all your support. You can
support us many different ways. You can
support monthly on Patreon. You can give
a onetime donation on our website. You
can buy some of our documentaries
online. And you can also wear your
witness and check out some of our shirts
on lightwear.shop.
Here on the screen, you see a couple of
uh supporters, subscribers who are
repping Lightwear. They're wearing their
witness. And we thank you guys. And if
you send a picture, we'll put it on the
show. And we can't thank you guys enough
for all your love and support. Today's
show is going to be about witchcraft. We
talk about witchcraft off and on, but
it's a topic that really just seems like
you can't exhaust this thing enough
because every time I go into a store,
it's just like, wow, I can't believe how
blatant this stuff is just in your face
now. There was a time when the most
witchcraft you saw was maybe Harry
Potter, My Little Pony, or something,
but now it's just like right there.
Here's a book on witchcraft in Walmart
and Target. It's really It's really
starting to be shocking.
If you check out Netflix, this this
screenshot was taken around October. So,
you know, maybe people say, "Well, it's
Halloween time or whatever." But these
are shows that are put out for children.
This is the top five when I took this
screenshot.
And number four says Scaredy-cats.
Number five says good witch.
Now, this is on the kids menu. Notice it
says exit kids. So, these are all shows
and movies that are targeted towards
children
pushing things like A Good Witch and
Scaredy-cats. So, what is Scaredy-cats
about? Scaredy-cats says right here, it
says, "On her 12th birthday, this is a
child. On her 12th birthday, Willow Ward
receives a perfect gift that unlocks a
world of witchcraft." Mercy.
It doesn't even say a world of, you
know,
fantasy magic.
Fantasy magic. You know, all these
pretty, you know, words
enchanting.
A world of witchcraft. Talking animals
and so much more with her best wait.
Talking animals and so much more with
her best friends.
Um, sometimes these genres even say
something like witchcraft. It's pretty
shocking. So, I mean, this is this isn't
us saying this is witchcraft when it's
really some, you know, people say, "No,
it's not really witchcraft. It's just
fairy dust."
Straight up. Yeah. They're calling it
that themselves that they're branding it
as witchcraft.
Because we've become so desensitized
over the years of accepting things like
enchanting and magical, and now it's
just like, let's just call it what it
is, witchcraft.
But it's promoting to the whole family.
Oh, yeah. you know,
family watch together TV and they call
it fantasy.
Wow.
Uh, good witch says,
which is a nice oxymoron there for you.
What? Oh, good witch, right? There's no
such thing. I mean, people argue there's
good witchcraft, white witchcraft, black
witchcraft. It's all witchcraft. It's
all one. It's just like saying
uh I don't know I'm a Republican or a
Democrat. They're all bad, right? Good
witch. It is an oxymoron. It says,
"Raising her daughter in the small town
of Middleton, an enchanting widow with
magical powers provokes the interest of
and exasperation of a big city doctor."
Now, this is something I've noticed,
too. Have you guys noticed that there's
in in so many shows and movies, there's
always a widow situation? Have you
noticed there always a one parent thing?
It blows me away. I don't I don't
understand that. Every Disney movie is a
one parent person. Even we did a show
talking about witchcraft and it was the
upside down magic or whatever and it was
uh the camera was panning across some
houses and it's zooming in in the window
of the girl and she's like ever since my
mom died blah blah blah or whatever.
It's just like why does it start?
Yeah, let's set the stage. I have one
parent
and I don't I don't understand the whole
step steparent thing
but it says an enchanting widow and they
tell you that right there in the
description.
Uh again the genre fantasy family watch
together.
So then that's Netflix, you know, but
what about in the toy world? Have you
guys seen any witchcraft toys out there?
Yeah. Well, it there's dolls dressed up
in witch clothes or costumes that kids
could put on that's very much witches
and goblins and these things.
But you mean like an actual toy
dedicated towards?
No, I haven't seen that. Although I
guess
I don't even know kids still play with
toys to be honest.
I haven't been to the toy section in a
long time.
I thought Toys R Us is out of business.
No. Yeah, maybe.
Do they have Harry Potter toys still?
No, they do have Harry Potter toys with
wands and it's like and you watch the
commercial and they're like zapping each
other. And I remember being in the toy
section when I was in high school and
there was a broom, a Harry Potter broom
and you sit on the broom, right? And you
push the the button and it goes just
starts vibrating and making these whoosh
sounds and I'm like
I don't know if that's a good toy for a
child to be sitting on that vibrates.
But there's still like there all this
witchcraft stuff and these perverted
toys that we've talked about on other
shows about dolls wearing lingerie
underneath their clothes and you put
them in cold water and suddenly they're
dressed like a prostitute.
I remember those. Yeah.
But uh let's just check out this toy.
It's kind of new as of last year and
just it's it's mind-blowing.
Magic Mixies. Mix your potion. Make your
pet.
Magikers mix. Just like magic. Your
mixie is here. Magic Mixies. Who will
you magically create? Each sold
separately.
What do you see on this table?
Potions.
Potions. Yeah.
What's that last thing on the right over
there?
Oh, a spell book.
Spellbook. This is literally a cauldron
as a toy.
A cauldron with a magic wand with
potions and a spell book.
We're We're leaving nothing to the
imagination. No fairy dust, no pixie
dust. It's liter It's just like the
Barbie that was doing the guided
meditation where you listen to your
Barbie walk you through doing transental
what transcendental medit meditation.
This is a toy that's telling you, put
the potion in, tap the wand three times,
and and then out comes this little demon
as your pet, they say, "Make your own
pet."
I mean, this is
a nice lighted third eye.
Oh, yeah. The illuminated third eye.
When you look up Netflix top witch
shows, I mean, there's
tons of them. You wouldn't
Great.
And this is just what I could fit in a
screenshot. Which one of these like
stand out to you guys?
Sabrina.
Yeah, I've seen
Yeah, I remember Sabrina because I think
on a previous show we talked about how
um was it the Satanic Church? I got
really upset when the Baffomet statue
was in that scene
and they were really upset about that.
They said it was out of context.
Yeah,
because a Baffomet was in a show about
witches. Um, I don't think that's out of
context, but it was interesting that
they actually sued over the, you know,
ruining the reputation of the Church of
Satan. And yet Christians don't, we just
sit back and and we're
our gods blasphemed, our our religion's
mocked over and over. You know,
Christians are made to look like dorks
and everything in all these movies.
I think someone actually wrote us asking
to expose Little Witches Academia. And I
looked at it and I was like, "Expose
what exactly?" Yeah,
because
it's called Little Witches Academia.
I think we could um just stop there.
Yeah, they're probably gonna teach you
everything they're watching.
We do get a lot of requests for like why
don't you expose this movie? It was so
satanic and a cult. And it's like some
things just
I hope don't require us to like break it
down. Like, okay, right here it's a
witch. Right here they're killing
somebody.
But that's not to say you shouldn't send
in your requests. I mean, we we look at
all of them and take all of them quite
seriously, but it's good to have shows
like this. Good job, Mikey. Because
you're pretty much bringing it all
together and showing like a a broad view
like, hey, this is this is everywhere.
This is
in your face and um showing principles
on how to make these decisions, you
know, on your own and use discernment.
If it says charmed, witches, and
yeah, you know,
supernatural, the Witcher, the
magicians,
and Charmed is they still aired that on
TV, I believe. It's it's very popular. I
don't know if they is that a remake or
if they remade it. Yeah, I know that's a
very popular one. I haven't watched it
myself, but I do have family members who
who have watched it.
Oh, so the craft got rebooted, charm got
rebooted.
Yeah, I mean I remember my first LED
that we did in English. It was the uh
witchcraft, you know, stuff like that.
And we were I was showing things about
the Sabrina,
but the thing is that they're putting a
young girl attractive.
Yeah. And it's not just like, okay, it's
evil and they talk about, you know,
witches and all stuff. No, the thing is
that how they gonna call you so you can
be involved in that kind of stuff,
right? So, you putting a nice girl
there, attractive, and it's like, hey, I
really want to be like that, you know?
So, that's the attraction there.
And I and I know, you know, they're
cartoons for young girls. I mean, for
kids, you know, and like this one is
for cats and everything. I was like,
wow. I mean, everybody love cats, but
they have these behind the scenes, you
know, these stories, dark stories, and
and I can imagine. I mean, I mean, you
just went to Google and just type
Netflix stop which shows and look at the
whole list,
right? That's all that would fit in a
screenshot. I mean, there's there's more
than that.
So, what I thought was interesting was I
was at a grocery store and I saw Life
magazine. you know, this is mainstream,
uh, you know, just about random topics,
but the whole this is a whole magazine
dedicated to the Salem witch trials. So,
I was like, that's interesting. So, I
start flipping it open to see what they
say. And right here, it says, "A brand
new witchy world, modern witchcraft.
Forget the dusty stereotypes. Today's
magical practitioners are vibrant and
diverse, embracing a nature centered
spirituality that evolves and grows with
each new generation of witches.
It doesn't sound true,
huh?
That's true.
Yeah. That's what's happening. It's
being more acceptable now. It's like,
you know, you have your soccer moms
going to yoga and stuff, but now this is
becoming just as popular as that. And
and yoga is just as deceptive. And
this is I don't know to me when I see
yoga and stuff it's it's a little more
deceptive and I can understand why
somebody would slip into that it's all
about light and love and you know
meditation and trying to find peace and
calmness but this is literally about
casting spells
and instead of praying or whatever
you're doing rituals you're you know
wrapping sage and burning it all around
your house and you're making pentagrams
with salt and Yet it says, "Forget the
dustial stereotypes."
It goes on to say, "In western culture,
witchcraft is no longer an abbreviation
punishable by torture or death. Instead,
we've entered an era when witches,
Wiccans, and other neopris
can freely practice magic spelled with a
K actually say that
to distinguish it from the type of
illusions performed by stage magicians
in a multitude of ways. as varied and
unique as the millions of individuals
incorporating in incorporating it into
their lives today.
Well, I mean I I feel like everyone
should have seen this coming because
this is that's what this country stands
for. It's freedom, freedom of
expression, religion, etc. That doesn't
mean that we should join it just because
it's ex not acceptable. Is it
acceptable? Like that that's the that's
not the word I want to use, but like
it's allowed so to speak, but that
doesn't mean that we should join in with
it. Um, it's just this hard thing. It's
like we don't I wouldn't want it to be
legislated away or banned or not be able
to so be sold in stores because once
that happens, the next step is to ban
Christianity and else. Um, but on the
other side, it's like, yeah, just
because it's there doesn't mean you
should be involved in it. It doesn't
mean that you shouldn't guard against it
and we should have parameters in our
homes, especially when it comes to this
stuff. But isn't it interesting when
when Christianity is put in the
limelight, it's normally in a negative
sense.
That's right. Yeah. In the media. That's
right.
And and yet witchcraft and and yoga is
all like, "Oh, it's wonderful."
Mhm.
No, that's exactly where it's going,
too. I mean, when you put this in front
of people constantly. I mean, this has
been going on for ages.
If you remember the black and white TV
show Bewitched, right? She would wiggle
her mouth or something like that and
then her nose. Was it her nose? and uh
then something would happen or something
would change and you had the neighbor
that was always over here trying to
figure out what was going on and um they
have been doing this forever. But when
you put it in front of people's faces
constantly, it becomes desensitized and
you maybe want to, hey, what is that all
about? Oh, don't get that toy for the
kid. It's not that big a deal. And they
grow up and they're like, hey,
so and so down the road is actually
doing this stuff for real. Maybe I
should check into that. I mean, it's a
slow progress that just keeps going
down.
Yeah. It's all about just conditioning.
Um, so there here's just a little more
about it talking about tarot and all
that. I mean, there's a lot in this, but
I mainly just want to show that they're
they're portraying it like, hey, this
isn't something we should be burning
people at stake for. It's not that big a
deal. It's, you know, embraced and it's,
you know, talking about it promotes
feminism and all this stuff. And that's
another thing is it's really sucking in
females because it seems empowering and
stuff. Then there's a show called Witch
Hunt. I seen this trailer and I want you
guys to just respond to what you see.
What What do you see being promoted in
this? What kind of emotion is it
invoking, evoking? And what do you think
the viewers are going to walk away
feeling after they see this movie?
[Music]
I'm with the federal branch of the BWI,
the Bureau of
Wishcraft Investigations. I'm familiar.
I've been dispatched to follow up on
report of suspicious activity.
May I come in?
Detective, I assure you, there are no
witches here.
We need to stop. We can't be risking our
lives for them.
These women are born with their powers.
They don't have a choice.
Have you ever made anything fly?
How am I supposed to control something
that I'm not even allowed to practice?
Why does it have to be bad? I'm not bad.
I thought that I could keep you safe and
I can't.
Keep quiet.
There's nothing in that thing that
shouldn't be there, is there?
No.
I hate liars.
You want to try?
Isn't that interesting how they make it
moral?
Yeah.
I'm not bad.
That's That's something. That's just
something.
What's concerning is there's a message
of you don't have a choice.
No.
Did you catch that?
I did. That's that's the second thing I
thought was interesting. But then the
last phrase or sentence in this um
trailer was a question. Do you want to
try?
So there's a choice. Yes or no?
And so to take away that and say no, you
it has to be yes. Because inside of you,
you have to like,
you know, indulge this thing is wrong.
It's contradicting. But of course,
what's the the the loudest thing in this
is like, no, it's good. You know, come
on and join it. Be who you want to be.
Be who you are. There's
I was born this way,
right?
Yeah. Another another thing about
sympathy of evil, right?
Yeah. There you go.
Like, you know, oh yeah, I mean, poor
them and
another chance. I mean, I don't know.
Let's try this. And I mean, you you born
like that. You have powers and
it's okay. I mean,
you were born demonpossessed. Let's just
accept you that way. Let's keep you that
way.
There's always a beginning. And I feel
like the message of you were born this
way. You don't have a choice. Kind of
takes that away. Don't even look at it.
Don't even try to investigate. Don't see
what happened before. just just believe
that your present state is who you are
and what you can always be
which is incorrect
right I I looked up the name of the cop
I can't remember um but the name of it
was something to do with God it was like
and he's a he's a cop he's a you know
upholder of the law knocks on the door
and he says can I come in you know Jesus
doesn't come in unless he's invited in
and he's standing at the door and he's
knocking
and then he's like are there any witches
in here and then it shows him like in a
negative light like I hate hate liars,
but God does hate liars. And these and
they will have part in the lake of fire.
I really see this as a a painting of,
you know, making God look evil, making
those who are upholding the law look
evil and and the witches are the ones
you feel the sympathy for. the
the emotional music keys in. She's
crying. And then you get these things on
screen, these quotes that says, uh,
"This perfectly mirrors societal
prejudices in this alter alternative
story of America." Societal prejudices.
And I wonder what the water is about.
Why they kept getting dipped in water,
right? Yeah.
Or bringing it to life or like it
bubbling.
Yeah. Cuz it was floating. also like
when she and the glass but I mean they
were in a pool like they were submerging
them in pools. I wonder what that's
about.
Refusal of baptism.
The most the most memorable and creative
entries into witching cinema in quite
some time.
Why why would you want to watch that?
So his name is Detective Hawthorne. I'm
gonna look it up real quick. Considered
by some as a source of Jesus crown of
thorns.
Wow.
So that's the name of the cop. Who is is
he the good guy? No, he's the villain.
The one who's upholding the law and and
uh you know killing the witches.
And it's just like we look at the we we
were just looking at that article about
you know get rid of the dust steel
stereotypes where they're killing
witches. You know this is something to
be embraced. It's uh empowering females
and all these things. And then this
movie is just all about sympathy for
those practicing witchcraft and making
the upholders of the law look evil. I
hate liars. We're going to dunk you in
the water because you're a witch.
Um, this is getting so open and
acceptable now that Teen Vogue, the
target is teenage girls, Kylie Jenner
posed naked and covered in blood to
announce her new Halloween collection.
Since when did we start promoting nudest
things in teen magazines?
Then, um, Kylie Jenner, this was the
most not graphic picture. I censored it
out. It's totally not censored. This is
her Instagram, and there's multiple
pictures from the shoot, but she's
literally covered in blood.
Yeah, I think she took this down.
Really?
I think um people were complaining about
it. Um, but I think the last time I
tried to go look at this, which is a few
weeks ago, it was taken down.
Wow. I'm glad I got the screenshot.
Yeah. after 14 million people saw it.
Yeah.
Yeah. And you know, I took this
screenshot back in October, and this is
in Teen Vogue. This is what they're
promoting to teens.
So, I guess it doesn't matter. But what
what is that really? Blood? I mean, is
it blood from something? Did you look
into that?
You guys say you doubt it, but man,
people are like, "This is art." Either
way,
blood from the slaughter house. I mean,
I don't have any proof, but it looks
pretty real. I mean,
yeah.
Then also in Teen Vogue on the on the
line of blood and witchcraft, look at
these articles. Sex magic is helping
these witches achieve their dreams.
Is that their version of manifestation?
Dude, this is
the magazine for teenage girls, man.
Sex magic.
Oh, this is Oh, yeah. This is Teen
Vogue.
Teen Vogue. Wow.
I thought these were podcasts for some
reason.
Wow.
A Real Witches Reviews. A Real Witch
Reviews Netflix. brand new cherry
flavor. So, there's a show called brand
new cherry flavor, but we're getting the
we're getting the review from a real
witch.
Um, down here, celebrate Friday the 13th
with magic and manifestation. Like, this
is what's mainstream being promoted in
teen vogue. These are the articles. So,
when your daughter says, "Hey, mom, can
I get that magazine? It's for
teenagers." This is what they're
reading. Minstal blood magic, three
spells for your period.
Mercy. Teen Vogue magazine.
It says, "In this installment of
practical magic," so this is a ongoing
article, practical magic, Lisa Stardust
explains menstrual magic and how to use
your periods to connect with yourself.
Always remember that magic is for
believers, but this column can also
simply serve as a guide to getting in
touch with yourself. So even if you're
not a believer in magic, you can just
get in touch with yourself by playing
with your menstrual cycle. Even though
it's completely natural, modern society
has stigmatized ministration.
Sorry. To that point, that is validating
what we've been saying that doesn't
matter whether you believe in it or not.
If you're just playing with it, it
works,
right?
You're you're opening yourself up to
this stuff.
Wow. That's a good point. We've all seen
how that stigma is spread from tampon
commercials showing women discreetly
discussing their periods to the way we
hide our own men our own ministration
when it's our time of the month rather
than play into this patriarchal shame.
Oh my goodness.
Witches and other masters of magic
believe minstration is a gift from
nature.
I hope this is not what they meant by
this is like feminist and woman
empowerment. Oh man, I've seen women
rubbing their whole face with men min
menstrual blood.
In witchcraft, one's ministration
menstrual cycle is considered to be an
extremely powerful time, particularly
when it lines up with the full moon.
Though it should be noted that
scientifically speaking, the moon does
not influence when you get your period.
Our menstrual cycles can connect our
bodies to the universe, which is the
intent of magic. So, in that way, it's
true. Periods are magic.
Okay. Wow. Why can't we just keep it
simple? Your body is literally trying to
expel something and you're like, "Wait,
wait, wait. I can use this." And then
you put it back on yourself.
Oh, I I have to expel something quite
frequently. I'm not going to play with
it.
Yeah,
dude. This is nuts. This is like This is
what's being pushed in a teen magazine.
Yeah. This is so out of this world. I'm
sorry. I mean
I hope this is
how bad it can I mean how bad is gonna
go you know
[Music]
when are we gonna be at the same point
as Sodom Gomorrah
right
or are we there
yeah I think it's crazy that it is
becoming something that um it's it's
becoming part of our culture because
then it is going to get to a point where
it's like that's just the way it is you
know kids are going to grow up into this
they're going to teach their kids this
you know and it's just Like I don't
know. That's crazy. Like this could this
is how life is taking shape right now.
Yeah. Like I wouldn't even be talking
about this if it was in Wiccan magazine
or something. You expect it.
Yeah.
Teen Vogue. I'm talking like all the
articles are about, you know, a witch
reviews a movie. Uh here's how to do
menstrual magic.
It says menstrual blood can be used in
spells to ward off evil and protect us
if used properly. I mean, this is just
mind-blowing, guys. I can't I can't
believe where we're at.
Um,
there's You guys can read this article
for yourself.
I went to
Target and I was just shocked at the the
books that were on the shelf.
This is a video and and it might go by
kind of fast, but just look at the
titles of the books that are just just
right there on the shelf with everything
else.
The Orphan Witch. This is your destiny.
Crystal Zodiac.
Inner witch. A modern guide to get into
your modern uh inner witch. The black
arts. Color your own tarot.
Burn after reading with an allseeing eye
on it. And this one that says witchcraft
therapy.
Yeah.
Target.
Witchcraft therapy at Target. you guys.
Not just that, at Books a Million, you
can literally get
spell books and sage and crystal healing
with the whole howto step with it as
well. Like, it really is. And it's not
even Halloween. Like, this is just
this is here, you know? It's not a
seasonal thing. This is here year round.
All eye crystal potion. And it says uh
witchcraft therapy, your guide to
banishing BS and invoking your inner
power.
So this this I just want to be clear.
This is not something that we're doing.
When you say something or when you when
you do something, when you say a spell
or you do some kind of weird uh
Hollywood, it's the Hollywood is what
I'm calling it. The the magic wand or
whatever it's called. You're actually
using an entity. That entity could stick
around and what if he doesn't like what
the rest of this time you're doing,
right?
You know, you are opening yourself up to
all kinds of stuff when you open this
book,
right? The there's no power in,
you know, saying a spell or whatever.
It's the powers that be. It's the the
spiritual world world working. When you
say a prayer for somebody to be healed,
for you know whatever the prayer is
about, when that thing comes to pass,
it's nothing that you did.
You prayed. God heard your prayer. He
answered the prayer. Now, when you start
striking a a sun salutation pose and
yoga, you're sending a message to the
spirit world. They're inviting me in.
They're that's a salutation to the sun.
I I can come in there. They have a
Buddha statue on their shelf. That's an
invitation. They're playing around with
uh you know, sage and and putting it all
around their house. That's an
invitation. When you start doing this
stuff, you're letting the spirit world
know, I'm inviting you in and I want
power from you.
Yeah.
You're just deceived in thinking that
the sage has some kind of power.
I think it's also twisted because it's
like um when it does come to
Christianity, we we give God all the
glory and credit to anything that we do.
But then it's like with witchcraft and
like new age things, it's like I did
this. I manifested this. But it's crazy
twisted because you had to channel
something to get that power. Like you do
not have that on your own. You had to do
something to achieve that. So it's just
crazy how you almost have to do more
work on Satan's end, right?
But you like people still reject Christ.
Like I think it because it's like the
they're requiring you to do two things
is to tune in with them,
you know? So, it's just crazy how like
Yeah. It's just it's just twisted to me.
Yeah. We we posted this on our community
tab uh not too long ago, but this is a
type of merch that is sold by Disney.
These are Disney official
shirts. And uh this one says lose your
soul right there on the zipper. This one
says, "Avoid the light with demon wings
on the back of it." Avoid the light.
What What positive message is coming out
of that?
Yeah,
avoid the light.
This one says, "One bite and all your
dreams will come true." Who are you
seeing? Say that,
right?
Wow.
The serpent literally one bite and
you'll be like God. You'll be wise. All
your dreams will come true.
Your nightmares will too.
Yeah. Risk now, regret later. And it's
showing the apple, the symbolic of the
fruit. Uh, bad witches club. Why be a
princess when you can be a a queen?
Think of that.
Wow.
Prophetically.
Yeah.
If we're the bride of Christ and he's
the prince of peace, that makes us a
princess, right? Why be a princess when
you could be a queen? And the queen is
the witch.
Wow.
Join the witches club. This is Disney,
guys.
Yeah.
I mean, this is so in your face. It's
like this isn't us just
wow
twisting something. People try to say
that we we make something out of nothing
all the time, but how can you how can
you deny this?
That's right.
I went to Walmart the other day and this
was what I saw right there at the
checkout line. I turned around and saw
this shirt and I'm like, I I got to get
a picture of this cuz this is straight
up a tarot card with an allseeing eye.
The monarch butterflies, the sun and the
moon, the inverted pentagram right
there. Like all these are kind of
rounded edges and this one's just sharp
and like look at me. I'm pentagram.
Yeah. With the the planets and
everything in alignment and uh this is
the Roman numeral 18. I'm not sure if
anybody has any wisdom about numerology
or something.
I think you listed like five symbols
right there. And someone's probably just
like, "Oh, it looks cool. I'll get that
one."
Right.
But sadly, some some people do just see
this as a pretty shirt. Like they don't
even have any. They're like, "Oh, like
this is nature. There has there's
flowers on here. It's just the sun and
the moon and things like that, but it's
like
and the glaring eye of God. I mean, what
is that? Like
it's on the back of our dollar bill.
Relax.
It's true. When I was a when I was a
kid, when I was like nine and 10 years
old, I remember going to the mall and
there it was a trendy thing to have a
ring with an eyeball on it. And I
thought it looked so cool as a kid.
Like the magic or the is like the blue
one or the black one?
There was all different kinds. you just
like whatever color you wanted, but it
literally looked like a human eyeball
embedded into a ring. As a kid, I just
thought it looked so cool. My parents
like, "No, that that looks weird." And
my parents weren't completely
knowledgeable on all this stuff. They
couldn't give me a reason why, which is
what led me down the path of that
because I'm like, Christians just think
if it looks weird, it's wrong. If it
looks weird, it's of the devil. And I
can't tell you why, but that's just
evil. And so that's why I have a passion
for talking about why this stuff is
evil. why this how this stuff is just
infiltrating our culture to where it's
accepted
and and why we should stay away from
these things. It God isn't trying to
keep anything good away from us.
There's a reason he doesn't want you
playing around witchcraft because you're
literally messing with the demonic
realm.
That reminds me of a Bible verse in I
think it's Psalms. I don't remember
where
um exactly, but it says those who those
who love the Lord lack no good thing.
Yeah.
Exactly. It was crazy how that spirit
kind of twisted something good and pure,
which is intuition.
You know, if you sense something is bad,
do you always need a reason why? I mean,
better to be on the side of caution
than to search and and see, you know,
what's really up. But I do agree, yes,
we should have the answer because we
should seek and find the answers because
that's exactly what the word tells us to
do. And those answers are found in the
Bible.
Be ready always. So, I I you know, when
I was looking into like witchcraft and
demonic possession and stuff, I actually
read a Bible verse,
um you guys know about Legion
and what that guy was doing.
Yeah.
I want to read that verse real quick
here.
So,
in here it says
Mark 5:5 says, "And when he was come out
of the ship, immediately there met him
out of the tombs. was a man with an
unclean spirit who had his dwelling
among the tombs. So this guy's living in
the graveyard and no man could bind him.
No, not with chains because that he had
been often bound with feathers and
chains and the chains had been plucked
aunder by him and the feathers broken in
pieces. This is supernatural. Nobody can
I mean
I can't give Brad as big as he is. He
can't break a chain in half. But when
you're possessed by a demon, it there's
a supernatural power to that. That's
what's happening with people who are,
you know, they start messing around
witchcraft and they see things happen
and they feel empowered. They feel some
kind of power because there is a power
in there.
Neither could any man tame him.
And always night and day he was in the
mountains and in the tombs crying and
cutting himself with stones. But when he
saw Jesus afar, he ran and worshiped him
and cried with a loud voice and said,
"What have I to do with thee, Jesus,
thou son of the most high God? I adjure
thee by God that thou torment me not."
For he said unto him, "Come out of the
man, thou unclean spirit." What's
interesting is this demon-possessed man
worshiped Jesus. the demons recognize
who Jesus is and worship him
in a demonic form, you know, and but
what I wanted to point out here was this
cutting himself with stones, man.
Like trigger warning, you know, we're
going to be talking about this a little
bit because people were involved in
witchcraft. I I was in that world. I was
in the world of the occult and I hung
out with a bunch of Gothic people and
stuff and that's that's prevalent in
those circles where people are cutting
themselves and it's linked with
depression and all these things. But
what does the Bible say? This dude was
possessed
possessed to the point where he was
breaking chains but he was cutting
himself day and night
always night and day. And so I I heard
about this article,
this scientific article or American
psychological association says a new
look at self-injury.
Self-injury was well was is a
wellrecoognized clinical phenomenon but
it its causes and therefore its cures
have been somewhat elusive. Two clinical
researchers have compelling and
complimentary views on why people engage
in this harmful behavior. Now, they say
harmful behavior in that title, but when
you start reading this thing, they're
talking about how this is like
therapeutic
to cut yourself. It says, "When we were
both interested in knowing why people
hurt themselves, says Julie, but Joe was
focused on the possible emotional
benefits
benefits of cutting yourself."
Wow.
Uh of NSSI, which is non-suicidal
uh self-inflicted harm. And I was
looking at the motivations behind it.
While over their time their interest and
investigation have have converged, when
they first discovered each other's work,
we were like, "Oh, this makes so much
sense." Julie adds, "This is how the
various findings fit together. It was
very exciting." Um, it seemed very
strange to me and to a lot of other
people, says Franklin. Most studies on
the topic had relied on self-reports,
but I wanted to look at this
experimentally and biologically to see
if it was really true. Um, it says here
that
so they they did some studies on people
and it said a second finding was more
surprising. Everyone else reported
feeling better too, he says. So they're
saying that people are feeling better
after cutting themselves.
Sure. But
why would you feel better from
I mean well it's it's feel
I mean I don't have all the scientific
terminology but there's a high you get
or there's a there's a
yeah endorphins are released as the body
is is um
coping with
right it's like
adrenaline that's what it is.
There we go. Yes. To go and kind of fix
the problem and then as the problem is
being fixed then it kind of subsides. So
you're basically manipulating your body
into these different levels of euphoria
so to speak.
There's other ways to do that that are
not harming yourself.
Yeah. Right.
Yeah. And the fact that if if that's a a
coping me mechanism, it could probably
lead to some form of addiction and then
when the high isn't as great anymore,
then what are you going to turn to? And
then what does it mean by non-suicidal
um inflicting? Because as this gets more
and more intense, you're probably going
to try more like different
parts of your body, different areas. If
you don't have any kind of anatomy
training, next you know you slip and
then you hit a vein that's not supposed
I mean what
that's even very sensitive on your wrist
too because you have very important
veins there as well.
interesting that you know the enemy
wants us to cut ourselves you know
damage
because we are created as the image of
God right
the temple
yeah and also I mean Jesus said you know
what come to me you know when we had
those kind of bad problems
well what we don't go just go just like
the demon did you know worship God why
don't we just go to our knees to say I
need help
and that's what the demon I mean
recognize it say you What? He's the son
of God. I'm going to go with worship.
So, uh, right now, maybe you're watching
this show and maybe you you or your
friends there have this problem of
cutting yourself. That's just demon
possessed,
destroying God's image.
But let me tell you, we need to go to
Jesus' feet and say, "I need help."
Amen.
I need help because let me tell you, he
is the one that's going to help us in
this bad situation.
Amen.
That's awesome to see. Yeah. the very
one that was causing this man to cut
himself
went to his knees when he saw Jesus cuz
that's where the power and authority and
everything is
he had to bow the knee.
So I just, you know, I'm just seeing
these scientific psychological studies
and stuff and it's just it's just kind
of worrisome when you start seeing that
they're saying, well there's maybe some
kind of benefit to it. Um, I mean, if
you read the whole article, it might not
glamorize it or anything, but
yeah, I also like that in that passage
of scripture, it's demonstrating that
you can come to Jesus at your worst,
you know, because it's like sometimes we
think like, oh, I'm going through this.
God doesn't want me. He's mad at me. I'm
just too sinful. But it's like this man
was demonpossessed, you know, isolated
from everybody, cutting himself, crying,
depressed most likely, and he he ran to
Jesus and Jesus healed him, you know. Of
course, it's not going to be as instant
sometimes, you know. But yeah, it's just
like that's encouraging to know that you
don't have to be like in whatever I
guess dark hole we are, we find
ourselves in, Jesus can always pull us
out of that.
Yeah.
Amen. Even when you're messing around
witchcraft and all that. But the reason
I even brought that up is because
like I said in those social circles of
the goth or whatever,
witchcraft and cutting and depression,
all that, it goes hand in hand.
I I see a connection when the Bible says
don't mess around with witchcraft and
this guy's demonpossessed and he's
cutting himself and depressed and crying
and hanging out in the graveyards.
That's what we did.
Me and my friends would do all that
stuff.
And I think there's a clear link. And
when you got the the youth growing up
like oh it's the scaredy-cats show or oh
it's the good witch or whatever. This is
where this path leads to destruction to
to messing around with something that's
going to open up a gateway that could be
a very strong hold in your life. very
stronghold that the enemy has and to to
where you're going to not just
destruction of your soul, but
destruction of your your temple, your
body, that could lead to like what
you're saying, like it could possibly
lead to
death.
And if you're dealing with,
you know, suicidal thoughts or
depression,
like you said, we need to run to Christ,
man. That's where the power's at.
I think I think, like you said, it can
release endorphins. It can release um
adrenaline when you do this. But the
fact that it has been going on for
centuries tells me, yeah, Bible days.
Not only that, not only back in Jesus
day, but far beyond that, too. I think
Leviticus 19 or something talks about
this and where it says, "Do not cut
yourself.
You know, I'm the Lord. You know, don't
be like these these people that aren't
of me."
So, not only back in Jesus' day 2,000
years ago, but long long before that.
And so, we have seen this. What makes
you I mean how is it that this has been
going on so long? Is it just because of
endorphins or is are we being influenced
by something?
There you go. Totally good thing to
ponder.
So I just want to end with this text
about witchcraft because a lot of people
ask, you know, what's wrong with
witchcraft? Isn't it just like I don't
know. They say it's the same as miracles
or something like that or that it's not
bad. It's just getting power from
nature. We we've talked about there's
nothing there's no power in sage smoke
in your house. You're you're doing a
ritual. That's a ritual that's inviting
demons in because
you're giving a signal to the spirit
world.
Deuteronomy 18:10
says, "Then he shall minister in the
name of the Lord his God, as all his
brethren, the Levites, do which stand
there before the Lord. They shall have
like like portions to eat beside that
which cometh of the sail of his part
patrimony.
When thou art come into the land which
the Lord thy God giveth thee, thou shalt
not learn to do after the abominations
of those nations, there shall not be
found among you anyone that maketh his
son or his daughter to pass through the
fire, or that causes or that uses
divination, or an observer of times, or
an enchanter, or a witch, or a charmer,
or a counselor of familiar spirits, or a
wizard, or a necromancer. For all that
do these things are an abomination unto
the Lord, and because of these
abominations, the Lord thy God doth
drive them out from before thee. Thou
shalt be perfect with the Lord thy God.
This is not a rejection from God. He's
not saying, "I won't accept you because
you're messing around with this stuff."
He's saying, "Because you're playing
around with these things, you've become
an abomination. You're inviting demons
in." The demons are not going to inherit
the kingdom of God. And when you're
inviting them into your temple, you're
literally inviting demons into the
temple of God. And now you have become
an abomination. And he cannot allow you
to inherit the kingdom of God.
The kingdom of God will be a perfect
place where there's going to be no
liars, no thieves, no adulterers. Praise
God, right? Who wants to live in a world
forever where people are like that? And
if you're practicing these things, don't
think that this verse says that you
can't come to God,
right?
It's an invitation to come to God. And
he's saying that you can be perfect with
the Lord.
And with God asking them to stop doing
this is a sacrifice. But within this
sacrifice, whoever decides to make to to
not do this, within that sacrifice is
mercy.
And we see that plainly with Elijah.
Elijah at Mount Carmel, right? Where
there's this, you know, battle against
gods. the the the the um no no the um
the counterfeit god Baal and then God
King of Kings, Lord of Lords. So you
have Baal's priests, they're going
around, they're cutting themselves,
they're doing all kinds of sacrifices.
And you know, that went on and on and on
with no reaction from their God. It was
in mercy Elijah says, "Okay, let's stop
this. My turn." Imagine how long that
would have gone on for until what? Maybe
people started dying because of the
amount of blood loss and all these
things
and then God steps in and we know the
story. He comes in in majesty and glory.
So we see God's mercy and saying no this
you don't need to do this and we know
that spiritual currency is blood and our
debt has been paid when Jesus died on
the cross. There is no need to engage in
these types of things. See the mercy in
the sacrifice.
Amen. Yeah. That's Satan's counterfeit
of Christ's blood. you know, we don't
have we don't have to have any kind of
physical blood to to make a
a prayer be answered or whatever.
Exactly.
So, what I see uh when people practicing
witchcraft, what is the result of that?
You know, towards God
uh in 1 Samuel, I'm going to share this
in 1 Samuel 15 uh verse 23. I mean it
says for rebellion
is a sin of witchcraft.
So it's rebellion.
Yeah.
So it's like you know what I'm against
to your god.
Right.
So when we practice that kind of stuff
it's not like oh I see power I want to
get that boyfriend or I want to get that
money or no when we practice the result
of that is becoming to hate God
against God.
When you bring you say hey let me show
you the word of God light. you bring
light to to that person. So, you know
what? I don't want to listen to that.
You got different spirit. I mean, we're
talking about,
you know, possession and all stuff.
When I was, you know, be outside in the
world. I mean, I didn't want to hear it,
right?
I didn't want to even look at a Bible. I
didn't want to see my brother.
Which shows the amount of power that's
in it. Oh, yeah.
Because if somebody said, "Hey, let me
let me read this thing from the new age
book." You'd be like, "Okay, let me I'm
kind of interested." I mean, you would
not have that spirit of like, get that
junk out of here. I mean, pretty much
anything, let me show you what Buddha
said or whatever. You'd probably be
like, "Sounds pretty good."
It is wrong to have a a picture of the
art of the sun or the moon,
you know, sometimes, I mean, if you guys
like art, I mean, I like, you know,
different colors, blue, and they also
have golden things, whatever. Uh but I
mean it it is just maybe if you went to
that store and they have that specific
you know shape of moon on sun or just
like any in general. What do you think?
I think it really comes down to your
choices. This is me. This is my personal
opinion, not the personal opinion of
anybody else in this room or because I
don't know what you guys believe. But
when we talk about these items and we
bring them into our house, if they have
been specifically set aside for
occultism, like we go to the store, we
go to Spencers or you go to, you know,
the the strange stores in the mall and
you go to, I don't know, Hot Topic. You
go to this place and you get this thing,
you bring it back to your house.
That could be dangerous. But if you just
have a painting of a sun on your wall
that someone drew, come on. It's not
that big of a deal. You have to go to
the source.
Yeah. It's it's uh it's what it's been
set aside for. And that's what, you
know, you got to put a little bit of
thought into.
There's layers to this. I mean, asking
questions, you know, why why is there
this burning desire to have a a sun on
your wall? And maybe maybe it's it's
innocent. Fine. Like, I'm not here to
criticize anyone, but someone asked me
this question once. I thought it was
brilliant. They said, "If the police
were to knock on your door, they come
into your house to arrest you for being
a Christian, would they find evidence in
your home to arrest you?"
So, the passion that you have for these
other things, is it the same for the
things that you truly believe in or that
you profess to believe in? Um, just
asking yourself simple questions, you
can get to the bottom of why you really
want this thing.
Um, my mom and I were gifted a a dream
capture and I was in elementary school.
The thing was beautiful. We hung it on
our rearview mirror of her car and then
she did some research and she found the
the origins of it and you know it's it's
to a culture a culture that's not of
ours and it's also um in contrast to the
beliefs in the Bible you know we
shouldn't look to a dream catcher to
take away our bad dreams we look to the
Lord.
I didn't want to hear all that. It was
just a nice dream catcher and I wanted
to keep it. It was a selfish motive like
this is a beautiful thing and I want to
keep it.
I don't care about other stuff. if I
didn't buy it or it was I wasn't gifted
this thing because of that other stuff.
Well, putting my own emotion aside, what
does the thing mean? What's the origin
of it? Get my emotions out of it.
There's other beautiful things that we
can hang on the on the mirror and and go
um take the steps in in that direction.
So I think it is a per it has something
to do with our personal feelings and
then also it has something to do with
research and so yeah we can't pick and
choose and say definitely do not have
suns in your home but get to the root of
things like just be open honest with
yourself and really
ask questions
I personally love nature so I would have
a painting of a beautiful sun on my wall
because I I love and that's that's
something that I struggle with because
now this is becoming so
um popular in our c like just um like
just new age beliefs
and everything that they sell is like
they're marketing it as you know reach
your higher self vibrate higher
manifestation divination exactly and
it's like
where can I find something that doesn't
have any meaning but like it can just be
what God created it to be you know it's
it's getting harder to find those things
now because
yeah but
I I think it comes down to like like
this God hates sin and he's trying to
bring us out of that, right? What if
let's let's bring it back to friends.
You're friends with some nice Jewish
people and you have a swastika in your
house.
Are you going to be like, "Hey, you know
what? Uh, come on over here." No, you're
going to hide that thing. You're going
to get rid of that thing. You're friends
with people that don't like that thing,
so get rid of it. Right? Does Does that
make sense? I think
Yeah. Well guys, we hope that you
learned something from this. We hope
that you could see that there is a very
real spiritual war going on all around
us. There are angels who rejoice at one
repentant sinner and there's demons who
are trying to whisper in your ear, yeah,
you know, get involved in that thing.
Play around with that witchcraft. Play
around with that minstal magic or
whatever it is. These things are not
something that we should be messing
around with just because it's accepted
in the mainstream and it's in the teen
magazine. Be careful what you guys are
reading. Be careful what you're dabbling
around in. And most of all, get in God's
word. He's got the answers. He even has
answers about cutting and all these
things. When you get into God's word,
seek ye first the kingdom of God, and
all these things will be added unto you.
You study the count, you study the the
truth, and the counterfeit will be
easily spotted. Thanks again for joining
us. Don't forget to check out
lightwear.shop shop and send us a
picture and we can put you guys on here
because we love you and thank you so
much for all your support and we will
see you guys next Friday. Later
[Music]